an electron
is moving
through the graphene in either a
right-handed state
or a left-handed state it has a certain
amount of energy it has a certain
momentum and it has a certain direction
of its real spin but it's also got this
additional property and it's this
property we're trying to probe in our
experiments we want to see if we can
pick up this right-handedness and
left-handedness of the electrons
this is our latest paper as you can see
is coming out in nature physics resonant
tunneling between the cairo lando states
of twisted graphene lattices well we had
a quite a tough time for the referees
they asked lots of questions and
i think the reply the referees was
longer than the paper itself but that's
common these days and the process was
was quite fast only took three months
and i have to say that although we moan
at the referees and papers they did help
us make the paper better so ever those
referees were thank you for your great
comments we moan about them but they do
a great job just like football and rugby
referees and qriket umpires let me start
first of all with gra the last word last
two words graphene lattices so we've
been looking at this material graphene
that's be that's been very exciting
since this remarkable properties were
discovered back in 2004 by andre gaiman
costing the boslof and their colleagues
in manchester they're their pictures on
my shelf
there you are one of them is an even
even a signed copy so what is graphene
well graphene is a two-dimensional sheet
of
atoms of carbon here they are the black
blobs are the carbon atoms and you can
see the atoms of each atom is bonded to
a nearest neighbor by a strong covalent
bond and we end up with this rather
beautiful hexagonal pattern each one of
these hexagons we call a unit cell the
idea is this is a periodic structure
that looks has got this very high
symmetry along along the axis and the
electrons in graphene we can get free
electrons some of the electrons are
stuck in these bonds but we can have
some free electrons that can move around
inside the lattice so that's what the
electrons are doing the kite these
chiral states with the states are the
electronic states of graphene
electrons like to sit in states whether
they're free electrons going around in
space or in this lattice where they're
moving as traveling waves they free
particles and we can think of the
electron as being um a ball of charge uh
we don't know how small it is actually
there's still nobody
as far as we know it's a it could even
be a singularity and the electron has
got several properties when it's moving
in free space it carries a mass
which is 10 about 10 to the minus 30
kilograms it's about one two thousandths
of the mass of a proton
it's got a charge of course and that's
really as interesting property carries a
big charge despite a small mass it
carries a quantum charge e
or minus e more strictly the electron
also spins uh just like a cricket ball
we can spin a cricket ball the electron
could spin either this way
in which case his spin is up or he can
spin the other way
in which case the spin is that spins
down so it does off break and leg break
i don't suppose any americans will
understand that but i think you could do
similar things with the baseball as well
well because we
created a single sheet of graphene uh in
the device as i'll explain the moment we
we pile graphene up with some other
material another material called boron
nitrite but the electron is just moving
freely in the plane of the graphene it
can go in this direction or that
direction as long as it stays in this in
the plane and the remarkable thing about
electrons in graphene is that their
speed is always the same no matter what
energy they've got the electrons of
course as you can imagine are going very
fast but it's only uh 1 300th of the
speed of light they can be going in this
direction this direction or this
direction so if we do nothing to the
sample
there's no net current flowing except at
a microscopic level however if we apply
a voltage if we bias this end of the
layer
negative with a battery and this end
positive then an electron will will move
towards the positive
contact so
and then it will drift
but
drift velocity it depends on how often
it's scattered the other key thing about
this sheet when you exfoliate graphene
from graphite by what's called the
scotch tape method you can just peel off
layer and layer of graphene if you've
got the right type of graph graphite to
start with you can have very very clean
and pure graphene and then the electrons
can travel long distances much this much
further than the distance between two
atoms
say
they can go for a micron or so without
scattering under certain conditions i
think the next thing to talk about is um
what a land that what are these landau
states well i've said that electrons can
be in free
particle states they can travel as
schrodinger waves down the crystal in a
certain direction and we can describe
that by that that motion is a wave like
motion according to schrodinger's
equation so electrons can travel freely
as in graphene but in hydrogen atoms
they're bound so if my fist is a proton
of hydrogen atom then the electron can
orbit around that and then it's in a
a localized state and that state now has
a well-defined energy level
whereas when electrons are moving freely
depending on what the momentum is they
can have more or less any energy they
can have a small engine a large energy
depending on their momentum
so those are states now
our electrons in graphene are free
because the graphene is no not is so
pure there aren't any impurities for
these things to get bound to but
for technical reasons which i hope to
come back to later when we apply a
magnetic field
perpendicular to the plane of the
graphene sheet so the magnetic field is
now pointing perpendicular to the plane
then the electrons undergo what are
called cyclotron orbits the electrons
now move in a circular motion and so in
a sense although we haven't got any
um other charged particle binding the
electrons we can make them orbit
around the lines of magnetic field in
what's called a cyclotron motion
and when we do that
uh we bunch the energies of the states
together into what are called landau
levels those are well spaced they're not
equally spaced in graphene the levels
actually more higher up you go in energy
the levels get more closely spaced but
the arrangement of these states this
energy level scheme looks somewhat like
what happens in the hydrogen atom when
you bind an electron you've got the
ground state you've got excited states
and so on so it's very convenient if
we're doing really precise measurements
to look at
what the electrons are doing in
particular states and the transitions
they make between those two states in
order to study graphene we can look we
can look at the electrical properties of
single sheet but what we made a few
years ago was a transistor structure
where we combine
graphene with another material called
hexagonal boron nitride and i'm
representing that by this piece of
cardboard boron nitrous got a similar
structure to this except that
say this atom now is made of boron and
the neighboring atom is made of nitrogen
so it looks like this but we've got
alternate atoms of nitrogen and boron we
then place a sheet of graphene
above above the
boronite layer and then another sheet of
graphene and get it
underneath it so that's going underneath
it like this the graphene is a single
atomic layer we make the boron nitride
three four or five atomic layers thick
and then an electron when we put a
voltage on this electrode play a battery
across the two electrodes we can get
electrons to tunnel through the barrier
these electrons are moving in plane can
now tunnel
from this plane into the lower plane of
graphene
and we've been able to make a transistor
device out of that we can control the
current flowing through the device by
this voltage and another voltage we
apply to the to the substrate which
which holds the device that's that's the
so-called gate electrode but that's kind
of a technicality we don't need to worry
about at the moment tunneling now
tunneling is is a quantum mechanical
phenomenon that cricket balls and golf
balls can't do so for example if i
take this ball then if i throw the ball
like this i'm going to hold this tight
this is not realistic so i have to try
and catch it properly right so we go and
throw the cricket ball
dropped
let's pick it up again if i fire an
electron this and this this wall is nice
and elastic then the electron comes in
and bounces off the wall again i can't
get it through the barrier and classical
particles behave that way golf balls
cricket balls
footballs rugby balls
they bounce off walls the only way you
can get
the ball to the other side of the wall
is to give it enough energy kick it hard
enough or throw it hard enough so it
goes over the top of the barrier or over
the top of the wall like this so we can
do that the remarkable thing about
electrons is that if we make the barrier
thin enough we can make it tunnel
through
it just goes through like that it can
tunnel through the barrier by quantum by
quantum mechanical process called
quantum tunneling this is a subtle
process but you can actually understand
it in terms of the old
heisenberg uncertainty principle as you
know
energy is conserved in general but
quantum mechanics gives you a a slight
get out it's like borrowing money from a
bank i can borrow a lot of money for a
day as long as i take it back the next
day okay i may have to pay a bit of
interest in it with a heisenberg
uncertainty principle i can borrow the
energy interest free so what i do now if
i want to get this electron from this
side to there i've got to get it over
the barrier
but it doesn't want to go over the
barrack because there's got enough
energy so i borrow the energy for a
short time
and then
that gives it gets it over to the other
side and i immediately give the energy
back this happy process can't go on
forever tunneling isn't isn't like this
if i make the barrier sufficiently thick
we can think of the electron and then
requiring more time to get from one end
of the barrier to the other so i have to
to borrow the stuff from a longer time
and the chances of me being able to do
that gets less and less the thicker i
make the barrier but i can do the
tunneling and so very occasionally in
our structure the electron
hitting the bar the electrons on one
graphene sheet hitting the barrier they
can go through uh to the other side and
we get a then can measure a tunnel
current we can actually measure the
electrons the guys up in manchester are
brilliant at making these things they're
very delicate small things because the
graphene is only one atomic layer thick
in the very early devices we didn't take
very much care in ensuring that this
graphene layer the lattice of this
graphene layer was aligned
accurately with the upper graphene layer
in other words
we
you could see this we can make it create
a twist angle we can either line these
hexagons perfectly as i've tried to do
here
so that this bond is always parallel to
this bond
or i can twist them but of course if i
twist to 60 degrees then i get i get
back again to the same periodicity so
it's important to try and make sure that
these things are aligned they get
aligned
after every 60 degree rotation of course
because of the hexagonal symmetry of the
lattice so we try to get this twist
angle as close as possible and now we
can get it down to one degree or even
less if we are very very careful so
that's where the so they twisted when we
said they twisted they're only slightly
twisted in a good device and the reason
for that is that if the misalignment is
too big
then
we've got to worry about momentum
conservation suppose it's going along
this direction parallel parallel to this
these bonds here then if it has to make
a quantum jump and then find itself in
two misaligned a layer it's now going to
have to jump into a state where the
bonds are aligned slightly differently
and that has consequences for momentum
conservation and they can do it but the
electron has to do some kind of
scattering process due probably the
small amount of disorder in the crystal
but it's much better to do a cleaner
experiment to get these two things
aligned as strongly as possible and then
the chirality effect manifests itself
what's the chirality ah no we come to
the nub chirality is is a difficult
concept and even after about three years
of working on graffiti i still struggle
with it i'm pretty i think i understand
about momentum and energy conservation
but chirality is much more
rather more subtle it's a little bit
analogous to the real spin of the
electron the spin
all electrons have an intrinsic spin
they can go that way or that way and
spin can be either up or down it can be
you know going around one way or the
other and chirality is like that can
have two possible values
positive chirality or negative chirality
if you want to call it that i had to get
my
bag of winter clothes out today it's a
nice day but i found these just to
remind you that if we have a pair of
gloves
then we have here a left-handed glove
and a right-handed glove and of course
it's very easy my hand naturally fits
into the right-handed glove because it's
made that way but if i want to put on a
left-handed glove i have to struggle a
bit now you will make the point i'm sure
that if the electron is moving in the
lattice how can we tell whether it's
right-handed
or left-handed
well in order to do that we have to make
a measurement
because until we make a measurement we
simply can't tell we it's going to be 50
it's got a 50 chance of being in a state
like this or a state like this so this
is what we're trying to do in our
experiment we're trying to see if it's
possible when the electron goes if you
think of the glove as being the empty
state
and my hand as being the the electron
and i can either fill
i can either fill
this empty glove or empty state with my
hand which is the electron when the
electron tunnels does it does a
right-handed electron
go into an empty right-handed state
under the barrier of course it can't go
into a fill glove just as well i just if
my glove is already filled with my hand
i can't put another hand in electrons
behaving exactly the same way they obey
the pauli exclusion principle so i can't
pile an electron into a state that's
already filled and so i've got worry
about conservation of handedness when my
electrons are tunneling and do they
conserve their handedness and the long
and the short of
this is that remarkably yes the
electrons do conserve it
if we make good enough samples we can
see that it affects the current passing
through the device what makes them
left-handed or right-handed well this is
the the big question uh and it is a very
subtle effect but i think we can
understand it by now thinking of
right-handed and left-handed electrons
fitting into uh left-handed and
right-handed gloves
uh by referring back to the shape of the
crystal
if you if you look at the atoms here
around this
this hexagon
focus on this this this particular atom
you can see here we've got a bond going
off here to the to
the left
along this direction
and then we've got these two off-angle
bonds going this way that's that's the
case for this atom if we compare uh the
situation for the this atom for example
or this atom we can see we've got a
different thing that the bond that is
pointing along this direction now is
going off to my right and the two angle
bonds are going off in the opposite
direction so clearly this atom and this
little
arrangement of three bonds is different
from this atom and its arrangement of
three bonds
now the electron is moving through the
lattice
and although it's
its wavelength and it is much longer
than the uh lattice constant the crystal
it senses this in some way i don't want
to give it sort of human properties but
its motion is determined by the lattices
moving through and so this
the right-handedness you can see in fact
that
this this arrangement of atoms is just
the mirror image of this arrangement
and so this left and right handedness of
the mirror image
is is gives rise to the chorality of the
two electrons so if for example i were
dealing with if the crystal lattice of
graphene were a perfect square lattice
that would have a different symmetry and
i wouldn't have this effect i wouldn't
get right and so the zigzago lattice is
the origin of this
left and right handedness of the
electrons
some of the background
first of all why say the electron is a
sphere when we we think of the electron
actually as a fundamental particle it's
one of the building blocks of
of
the standard model and i can get
electrons occupying both of those states
there's an electron in this one and that
one which i represent by the red dots
here's my tunnel barrier